salut à tous ces pêcheurs de trésors
beaucoup de vent aujourd'hui mais on est
un petit port du canal du midi ou à côté
d'un vieux château donc on va s'cauet
pour tron en sport c'est parti pour la
pêche je m'intéresse
à
quelque chose
un manche de couteau dans notre siècle
peut-être aussi vieux que l'église
sympa
ouais
il faut se demander gens couraient
partout dans ce petit village mac et
poissons km moyens peuvent pas un
pêcheur de poissons
[Musique]
aux
48 chances
d'encore
et les normes
direct
[Musique]
voilà
mais qui jettent un rapport
onebeer
un antivols de vélo
et un burin
au au
nom y retourner
un parasol
[Musique]
non
ceku la france par un salut
en plus le temps se fait un peu menaçant
la
paresse qui les en bon état
et bien oui oui il est comme neuf
[Musique]
ouais c'est cool ça c'est ceux des
bateaux de l'ocs toujours les mêmes qui
font tomber dans le canal bravo alors
j'ai sorti un bout de cuir
pétanque et une pièce
away regarder sans accrocher ont pu
retirer vers la tv des pièces pas
belles trouvailles aubistes il entrouvre
la porte finalement
on voit ce que choc comme barbarian
hu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pétanque mais là c'est trop d'impôts
celui qui fut proche gagne les 10
centimes qu'on vient de pêcher
[Musique]
d'un couteau quand même
sympa sauvegarde pour faire 2
électrolyse ouais inox
bullshit inox
c'est ça ouais minutes encore gagné ni
té pa l'inox est écrit quoi là
c'est pas notre faute si les crises ne
s'attendait pas voilà
voilà on est sur le pont donc il ya
cette barre de fer donc ça sur une joie
d'y pêcher dans les séquences qui
pouvait pas prendre sinon ses propres au
boulot on va voir si le vaste hall aux
mecs j'ai chaud pain quotidien
[Musique]
c'est bon
je vois pas comment ça se fait que ça
vient
[Musique]
pas d'accord c'est un morceau de
l'ancienne barrière
attend aussi de pareilles
[Musique]
ok
lapins sont bons avec très peu de poils
d'un sochaux il tint bon vieux temps
ouais
quoi ce look 6e des péniches non non
ouais peut-être sait qu'elle devra
garder les clients ouais c'est possible
et qu'un truc bas
en basset chromie saint denis les
bronzes
on
va venir vous le restituer ce goulet
casserole
ah oui du coup on n'a pas tous qui
m'aimait les morceaux de parieurs 5
cumul ça tombe bien aussi on va
et l'âge et josacine au
froid encore de la barrière de
sa fashion pour les poissons sans par
milliers il ya une petite fille énorme
poisson
parce qu'ici c'est toi le poisson
alors tu peux peut-être m'aider là par
contre qu'à voir
il ya un gros truc lourds qui veut pas
venir
au cd guirlandes de noël non
énorme
ouais mais peut-être quand la barrière
est tombé
waouh
bon ben c'est bien une belle dépollution
et la gêne pas encore aussi pour le truc
est ici
donc on va finir de t'amuser avec les
branches
c'est quoi un panneau
contre jour
intermec regarde
et en plus c'est la vie le nom s'est
passé le monde et
sinon ouais c'est à côté par hasard mais
il est vivant mais il est plus beau que
les anciens que les nouveaux je trouve
le tournoi
selon le garde nos
souvenirs on l'a pêché les gars enfin
une belle trop et souches pour écoute il
va nous attendre de pied membres
[Musique]
petite cartouche
dédicace à tous les chasseurs qui
regarde cette vidéo
cette fraîcheur
au pot d'échappement
le moche ouais et pas très grand mais
elle est super fort - dans l'eau
quoi
ouais jose a service et un sapin de noël
pour de bon
allez à huawei et
si vous vous demandez comment ce sapin
at il bien pu arriver ici voici
l'explication
énorme
c'est noël avant l'heure
j'attendais
n'a pas le droit de faire ça c'est à la
mairie sa bombe alors laissé devant la
porte de la mairie alors non
mais ils on doit remplacer voilà un
vieil outil sur l outil commune lance
well manche c'est vraiment parce que ça
peut être mais il a bien pris
chercher quelque chose de très sales
regard du coup là
en dessous non pinsonneault revoir un
arrosoir
les pages a4
en joie c'est la fin de cette session de
pêcher léman voilà non nous on s'est
bien amusés à webhelp est choyé donc
voilà la plus belle trouvaille du jour
le canon de fusil encore une arme encore
une arme c'est on est abonné ouais c'est
ça nous ne reviendrons pas autre chose
mais
voilà ça je vais me remettre à sa place
donc en direction opposée pour réduire
les gens dans dans les vingt jours
ça va la corde pour un panneau c'est
pouvoir les fait tourner autour d'un
rond point d'accès des chances à la
prochaine à la semaine prochaine